fbi fans this is your official spoiler
warning if you didn't catch the show on
tuesday april 19th then you should
probably look away immediately the hit
global series is saying goodbye for now
to special agent maggie bell as missy
peregrim heads off on maternity leave
the actress is getting ready to welcome
her second baby with husband tom oakley
missy made her final appearance in a
very dramatic episode which saw maggie
trapped in a room with deadly sarin gas
we have an agent who's been exposed to
sarin gas she's unconscious three
minutes ago we need to get her out of
there now
away played by ziko zaki eventually
smashes his way into the room and saves
her just in the nick of time but maggie
is left hospitalized and unconscious
the episode finishes with maggie
recovering from the toxic exposure with
oa by her side
i can't do this
fbi showrunner rick ede discussed
missy's temporary exit telling variety i
think the sarin gas idea seemed to be an
exciting thrilling way to send her off
he added we just wanted to find a way to
credibly center off within the imaginary
worlds we're living in and make it so
that she can come back when she's
physically ready to come back